una búsqueda desesperada para encontrar
supervivientes
esta parte de la ciudad de recife quedó
irreconocible tras las fuertes lluvias
que azotaron zonas del noreste de brasil
provocando desprendimientos mortales
los grupos de búsqueda se quedaron allí
y encontraron el cuerpo de mi hermana
encontraron su cuerpo y otros cuatro
cuerpos con ella a la vía no han
encontrado el cuerpo de mi cuñado
al otro lado de la ciudad las
inundaciones han destruido familias las
lluvias torrenciales sumergieron barrios
de toda la región con víctimas
confirmadas alto en pernambuco como el
vecino estado de alagoas más de 6000
personas han acudido a los puntos de
ayuda el gobernador de pernambuco se
refirió a los esfuerzos para que llegue
la asistencia a los afectados osama de
sus pólizas las fuerzas armadas nos han
proporcionado tropas que están siendo
enviadas a los municipios nuestro
trabajo es seguir trabajando en las
áreas críticas y restablecer los
servicios dentro de las comunidades
esta es la cuarta gran inundación que
afecta a brasil en sólo cinco meses las
lluvias han llevado a los científicos a
preguntarse si el cambio climático
podría ser el culpable la mala
planificación urbana también ha hecho
que los barrios sean más vulnerables
pues muchos de ellos están construidos
en laderas lo que las hace propensas al
colapso